she she knew what it was like when she
was ugly for the door to hit you in the
face because men weren't holding the
door open struggle her personality is
good they actually come and shine free
[Music]
applaud for the throw the glow up
what did you say i said applaud for the
glow up girls
and that's the thing they're always the
funniest too
you're in a shop you've been cute you've
always like
you were never ugly come on come on i
had my
face were you ever fat
no i've always been athletic built
but the face is the body can be one way
but the face could be another
member like 50 of women
so i'm gonna wear a bag on my face
you could why do you why do you think
guys would have do like sex dolls
yeah
they don't really yeah
wow that's true
what do you think they say butterface i
don't care
like it's dark anyways we ain't gotta
see your face man that is true this is
crazy they sweat fifty percent of the
time on dating apps
man
oh my
yeah i believe that like some of my
friends have tinder plus and they're
just like
tender plus
man it's in the plus
that page
okay i'm gonna read super chat um i saw
one from zantians i saw him roast me
oh no i know hold on
okay um zasian 12. i'm quite sure twerk
sure twerking is just a stripper move
and a common one at that so i'm
wondering if strippers are becoming more
public than private
oh that's true
yeah
um 90 free top blue dress um forgive
your mom and return to your dad
because if you know what we're going
through
like you don't know he leaves this
comment a lot actually it's not just
this
like
i've like seen this comment copy paste
like you said that to me before
i'm like i'm good i'm like i'm like i
like my pants
um blondie you're missing the point like
you're missing a marriage when you are
in a marriage you respect your husband
and your family's name and your excuses
of its reality it's another reason why
men should avoid women with mindsets
like yours um frazier mcfly
if pearl hasn't had it only fans i would
subscribe oh my gosh
i'll do i've always wanted to only fans
where i'm eating
why sandwiches sandwich i just think
it'd be funny
get the memberships yeah like they think
she doesn't need to
um i'm 25. all right you gotta go 15
years and
head to only fans oh god
um lawrence bullock i'm loving your
channel and your legs bow chica bow wow
um david red um jess is looking fine
what's her body count five hundred
dollar super chat she'll tell you
yes exactly
max it out
sentience it's
sentience it's pronounced cop you
littori sperm rag someone get pearl a
dictionary
yeah i did not know that i'm sorry
sentence i don't know a lot of words
don't know what we're doing i don't know
look at i don't know a lot of words um
trevor lane um the girl with the glasses
is back she's so bad
um yes ma'am
you wanna you wanna put your ig in the
chat you want to put your ig it's gonna
be
put and
at the end of the day oh yeah it's it's
time to make them search for it yeah
it's on my it's on my story tell my
story
um
so
what
percent of girls do you think have dated
a bad boy
90.
all of them know
not all of them did you know what
one thing i've heard about a lot of
things you've said right daily is that
our most girls are run through but i've
learned in this life right it's the
circles we revolve around in 100
and it was only when like i was working
at university and i was in different
fields speaking to different types of
people that
they are living completely different
lives to what i'm living
so the people around them
don't know
and you can tell their virgins because
the conversations that they have they're
so innocent they don't they don't know
things and you're just like oh my gosh
there's
many people like you
but i would never have access to that
because i'm not in their circles in
order to do that you'll have to like
[ __ ] infiltrate a world at warcraft
like group and just like sabotage
would you guys pick a girl that had a
lower body count but less chemistry or a
higher body count and more chemistry
what do you mean for life yeah how high
is high though because
let's say plus or minus 10. one girl
slept with 10 less one girl slept with
10 more
well if one was on two then i'll be
alright then i wouldn't mind so i'll
take that okay let's let's say 12. then
let's say 12. one's at 12 one's at 22.
why is it 22. oh that's a hot one one's
at 12 what's that 22. yeah
i know i'm picking
who are you thinking oh um
well
if my if my you know
if my average is ten and if i'm saying
like tens of the max or like i said a
long time and she said twelve and we're
talking twelve or twenty two i'm picking
twenty two
with less chemistry yeah no more
chemistry if it's 22 right yeah yeah
yeah i'm pretty cool the pair of endings
yeah 12.
yeah i'm picking 22.
what do you think
for life you know
yeah i can't get lost in an arbitrary
figure i just have to pick 22 man that
to be with a dead personality for how
many years yeah but to know you're not
pleasing her in the bedroom
but yes that's assuming i don't have the
mad team you think
you think you're the best out of 22 yeah
100
out of 22.
got back yourself yeah if i see myself
as a high value that's just a lot of
dudes yeah there's a lot of dudes right
and i'm leaving and i'm number one
you put me in a room with them i'm
coming out alive
so what about when they're going
whatever what about when you see them on
the street and they're you know doing
that impossible i protect the bag
i'm not leaving the house what would you
what would you do if you oh actually
question what would you do if you were
on the street and you saw your girl like
she said hi to him and didn't pretend he
didn't existed with that right then it's
done there's there's many other 22s out
there
so then she's gone if she if she still
talks but but if you say you're the one
and she's been alpha widowed and she
approaches the dude that alpha widowed
her no but now you're bringing the
analogy of her getting off with it it
never happened to me but i'm saying if
we if for this purpose of the scenario
it did
then yeah it's done in it yeah because
there's still an opening so an alpha
widow okay
i don't have the definition pulled up
but an alpha widow basically is like
if a girl is a five or a six right most
people are average so most girls five
let's say five she sleeps with a guy
that's an eight
she falls in love with this man that's
why you always hear like girls in
situation chips like they seem to be
more common than relationships these
days
and the reason is it's because a small
percentage of men are sleeping with all
the girls and so the girl is so in love
with that guy that no other guy can
compare
so it doesn't matter who she dates after
they can't beat that guy that's why rola
tomasi says and you're kind of right
with what you're saying it's not about
the number it's about the number of
alphas so if like our girls only slept
with five dudes but one of them is